en voyant les images impressionnantes de
cette foule aux abords et à l'intérieur
du capitole vous pouvez avoir deux types
de réactions quand vous êtes un
responsable politique
d'ailleurs les communiqués et autres
réactions envoyer ses dernières heures
en témoigne après avoir condamné
fermement les violences la suite de
votre message dépend de vos relations
avec washington
voyons d'abord les alliés historiques
des états unis quand dans une des plus
vieilles démocraties du monde
des partisans d'un président sortant
remettre en cause par les armes
les résultats légitimes d'une élection
c'est une idée universelle celle d'un
homme une voix qui est battue en brèche
je suis avec beaucoup d'inquiétude ce
qui se passe à washington
la violence est incompatible avec
l'exercice des droits politiques et des
libertés démocratiques
j'ai confiance dans la solidité et la
force des institutions des états unis je
crois en la force des institutions et de
la démocratie américaine
la transition pacifique du pouvoir est
essentiel joe biden a remporté
l'élection
ton grave et soutien sans faille aux
valeurs américaines
emmanuel macron a même placé un drapeau
américain derrière lui pour son
allocution
mais tous les pays ne font pas preuve de
la même compassion certains dirigeants
internationaux ont sauté sur l'occasion
pour se rappeler au bon souvenir d'une
diplomatie américaine si prompte à
l'ingérence dans les processus
électoraux d'autres pays ce qu'on a vu
la nuit dernière et aujourd'hui en
amérique prouve d'abord à quel point la
démocratie occidentale est un échec et à
quel point ces fondations sont faibles
et fragiles
le venezuela condamne la polarisation
politique et la spirale de violence qui
ne reflète que la crise profonde que
traverse actuellement le système
politique et sociale des états unis avec
cet épisode malheureux les états unis
souffrent de ce qu'ils ont généré dans
d'autres pays avec leur politique
agressive
une manière d'ironiser pour caracas pays
où la tentative de coup d'état par wang
wei d'eau en mai demi
19 avaient pour beaucoup étaient très
fortement soutenu par washington
alors comment aurait réagi la diplomatie
américaine si ces images du capitole
s'étaient déroulées ailleurs sur la
planète
en tout cas voici celle relative à
washington hier soir en provenance de
l'ancien président américain george w
bush
c'est un spectacle écoeurant et
déchirant c'est comme cela que les
résultats d'une élection sont disputés
dans une république bananière pas dans
notre démocratie républicaine et si les
réactions varient selon les relations
diplomatiques entre les pays la
qualification attribué peut également
changer selon l'intérêt qu'un état peut
trouver un à soutenir un mouvement de
contestation un double discours que n'a
pas manqué de souligner pékin les médias
mainstream aux états unis ont
unanimement condamné cela comme un
incident violent en utilisant des mots
tels que bandits extrémistes traître et
ont cependant quels mots ont-ils utilisé
pour décrire les manifestants violents à
hong kong
il disait que c'était un beau spectacle
est présenté les manifestants violents
comme des héros ce démocratique et que
le peuple américain les soutenait je
pense que nous devrions réfléchir
attentivement à la raison derrière ce
contraste concernant l'attitude des
états unis entre ce qu'il s'est passé à
hong kong en 2019
est ce qu'il se passe aux etats unis
aujourd'hui la partialité des médias
américains c'est aussi ce que souligne
la diplomatie russe moscou en profite
pour remettre en cause le mode de
scrutin américain c'est une affaire
interne des états unis en même temps
nous attirons à nouveau l'attention sur
le fait que le système électoral et
archaïque aux états unis qu'ils ne
répondent pas aux normes démocratiques
modernes ce qui rend possible de
nombreuses violations et que les médias
américains sont devenus un outil de
lutte politique
la preuve que si elle laissera des
traces dans l'histoire politique
américaine la journée du 6 janvier 2021
pourrait aussi faire dax en termes de
diplomatie